be kind
for everyone you meet
is fighting a harder battle
every heart sings a song
incomplete
until another heart whispers back
we can easily forgive a child who is
afraid of the dark
the real tragedy of life
is when men are afraid of the light
only the dead
have seen the end of war
the heaviest penalty for declining to
rule is to be ruled by someone inferior
to yourself
i am the wisest man alive
for i know one thing
and that is
that i know nothing
never discourage anyone
who continually makes progress no matter
how slow
nothing can harm a good person
neither in life
nor after death
love is a serious mental disease
one of the penalties of refusing to
participate in politics
is that you end up being governed by
your inferiors
good people do not need laws to tell
them to act responsibly
while bad people
will find a way around the laws
the measure of a man
is what he does with power
ignorance is the root and stem of every
evil
there is truth in wine
and children
those who tell the stories rule society
human behavior flows from three main
sources
desire
emotion
and knowledge
education is teaching our children to
desire the right things
there are three classes of men
lovers of wisdom
lovers of honor
and lovers of gain
courage is knowing what not to fear
the best family is when the wife is
blind and the husband is deaf
you should not honor men
more than truth
treat your parents as you would like
your children to treat you
when men speak ill of thee
live so as nobody may believe them
an empty vessel makes the loudest sound
so those that have the least wit
are the greatest babblers
the world is boring
for boring people
bad people live to eat and drink
virtuous people eat and drink in order
to live
people
are like dirt
they can either nourish you and help you
grow as a person
or they can stunt your growth
and make you wilt and die
good actions give strength to ourselves
and inspire good actions in others
there is in every one of us even those
who seem to be most moderate
a type of desire that is terrible
wild
and lawless
poets utter great and wise things
which they do not themselves understand
any man may easily do harm
but not every man can do good to another
false words are not only evil in
themselves
but they infect the soul with evil
a dog has the soul
of a philosopher
if you were answered with silence
this does not mean that you were not
answered
win your friends not with empty flattery
but with sincere words of love
the greatest victory is overcoming your
negative thinking
without friendship
no communication between people has
value
you married a crazy woman if she says
you're perfect
when the word does not strike
then the stick will not help either
never forgive a friend who betrayed you
once
he will
betray you again
drunkenness
does not give rise to vices
it reveals them